en tout cas Florent vous avez dit j'ai
toujours habitué les gens à ne pas être
coiffé de la même manière en tout cas
c'est con parce que le fisc vous
reconnaît toujours et
maintenant mon stagiaire Tom villa
able de penser
vous êtes libre ici Tom heureusement que
je suis libre d'ailleurs parce que je
suis stagiaire donc je dis ce que je
veux je risque quoi qu'on retire mes
tickets resto j'en ai même pas voilà
n'aurait pas ma liberté de penser
Thierry moi par contre je sais pas qui
chante cette chanson mais
c'est qui c'est l'autre condo je sais
pas quoi non
en tout cas ce soir Thierry on a un
plateau de gâteau de ce soir là on a pas
rougir face aux Américains
c'est fort
mais bon commençons d'abord par celui
qui allait les idées de Brice
hortefeuille avec le physique d'un
comédien des Feux de l'Amour Geoffroy
Didier
Geoffroy Didier avocat au barreau de New
York et de Paris la classe si vous aviez
pas été de droite des Sky aurait fait
appel à vous et s'il n'avait pas été con
il aurait été président
Geoffroy Didier fondateur de la droite
forte alors là il y a un moment où ça va
être compliqué parce que entre la droite
la droite forte la droite dure l'extrême
droite bon en tout cas a priori la
droite forte tout est relatif parce que
pour Mike Tyson c'est une droite molle
en tout cas Geoffroy vous êtes membre de
l'Association des Amis de Nicolas
Sarkozy si vous aviez monté
l'association des ennemis de Sarkozy je
pense qu'il y aurait eu plus de
d'adhérents
Florent Pagny c'est à moi
j'adore Florent Pagny parce que c'est
l'homme qui chante ce qui pense voilà un
problème avec la presse qui chante
presque qui coule me casse les couilles
il y a un problème avec le fisc non
c'est un problème avec le fils ma
liberté de penser bon on espère juste
que vous aurez pas de problème
d'érection ça c'est le
en tout cas Thierry vous l'avez dit
Florent Pagny et c'est aussi une gueule
et un loupe alors après toutes les
coupes et teinture que vous avez faites
vous avez encore tous vos cheveux
Florence c'est quand même incroyable
alors je te donne le tuyau j'ai fait des
implants c'est vrai ça t'arrivera aussi
c'est la technique cheveux par cheveux
et ça marche très bien en tout cas
Florent vous avez dit j'ai toujours
habitué les gens à ne pas être coiffé de
la même manière en tout cas c'est con
parce que le fisc vous reconnaît
toujours et
puis bon bah le style de Florent voilà
vous l'avez dit Thierry voilà c'est vrai
que bon je sais pas qui est le styliste
de Florence ça doit être le zoo de
Beauval non mais c'est vrai non mais
Florent quoi il regarde un documentaire
sur Planète et impression de regarder
les reines du shopping voilà c'est cool
mon dressing
les crocodiles il appelle papa donc
arrête on arrête on arrête Augustin
trappenard c'est la famille c'est la
maison c'est Canal+ voilà vous venez
avec un nouveau projet d'émission qui
s'appelle 21 cm
vous n'êtes pas une catho droite qui
revient de vacances et non parce que
voilà Samia vous êtes une femme vous
êtes musulmane et vous êtes humoriste et
vous êtes ici pour nous dire lequel de
trois est le plus handicapant tout
simplement
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Geoffroy Didier Geoffroy à l'UMP vous
étiez rémunéré 8000 euros pour être
l'assistant de Brice Hortefeux à part
lui trouver des blagues racistes c'était
quoi votre boulot
ça c'est du temps ancien Samy Roseman
Samia avec votre look multicolore vous
attirez plus quoi le public les
ophtalmos ou les contrôles de police
et pour terminer Augustin Trapenard
Augustin votre émission sur Canal
s'appelle 21 cm votre émission sur
France Inter s'appelle boomerang c'est
des petites émissions ou une description
de votre anatomie on peut des deux un
peu des deux Thierry bonne émission pour
pour être
YouTube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu